[Música]
bienvenidos a esta nueva edición de
enlace conosur hoy desde el sambódromo
en río de janeiro para hablar del
segundo carnaval de la pandemia que ha
sido aplazado el día 20 de abril por
causa de la ola de contagios causada por
la variante omicron el sambódromo es un
edificio único en el mundo un proyecto
del arquitecto oscar niemeyer el mismo
que hizo la capital brasilia está
pensado exclusivamente para los desfiles
de las escuelas de samba y por eso es un
lugar icónico de los carnavales de
brasil
la pista del sambódromo mide 700 metros
y está rodeada por gradas que llegan a
recibir a 80.000 espectadores el año
pasado el coronavirus obligó a suspender
el carnaval y este recinto se quedó
totalmente vacío solo iluminado por
luces de colores sin embargo en marzo de
este año ese lugar va a recuperar vida
gracias a los ensayos técnicos de las
escuelas que van a llevar aquí mucha
alegría y muchas ganas para él fuera de
la época de abril visitamos algunas
escuelas para ver cómo se están
preparando
[Música]
para nosotros no cambia mucho carnaval
es carnaval da lo mismo si es ahora o en
abril la ilusión
esta escuela de samba suele ensayar en
las calles de un barrio llamado vila
isabel sin embargo desde que la ola de
omicron llegó como un tsunami la escuela
ha optado por practicar en este local
sin público donde solo son admitidos los
miembros que presenten el certificado de
vacunación
[Música]
por un lado es un poco agotador por
causa de los ensayos que tendremos hasta
abril pero por otro lado la expectativa
es mejor vamos a estudiar a ensayar y
vamos a cantar más para hacer un
espectáculo un poco más bonito de lo que
haríamos en febrero
[Música]
esta es la ciudad de la samba una
verdadera fábrica de los sueños aquí
están los talleres de las doce
principales escuelas de samba y es aquí
donde se confeccionan los disfraces y
los carros alegóricos para los desfiles
de abril todo está envuelto y mucho
secretismo para no desvelar ningún
detalle antes de los desfiles pero
nosotros conseguimos entrar en el taller
de la sanclemente una escuela de samba
eso sí con mucha discreción
aquí todos los años se trabaja a destajo
en los meses antes del desfile en
vísperas del carnaval muchos artesanos y
llegan a dormir aquí para no perder ni
un minuto del bien más preciado el
tiempo en río de janeiro carnaval es un
asunto muy serio
a liao carabobo atrasar el carnaval ha
sido bueno porque con ello las escuelas
de samba han ganado más tiempo a causa
de la pandemia o una gran pérdida de
materiales para nuestra producción
porque muchos containers no llegaron a
brasil esto hizo que hubiese una
búsqueda mayor de materiales con más
proveedores procura mayor inmaterial y
mayor iniciador es el carnaval no es
sólo una fiesta representa una
importante fuente de riqueza para la
ciudad el último carnaval en 2020 superó
todas las expectativas atrajo a más de 2
millones de turistas y generó unos
ingresos de unos 800 millones de dólares
centenas de artesanos dependen del
carnaval para sobrevivir está bien mejor
ahora la escuela de samba dio trabajo a
bastantes personas desde el punto de
vista del empleo el mejor
me encanta este trabajo y saber que
estos disfraces van a ser vistos en todo
el mundo
la peor parte se la llevan las comparsas
que antes de la pandemia reunían a
decenas de miles de personas en las
calles de río de janeiro para abrir sus
desfiles no han sido autorizados en
febrero solo pueden tocar en fiestas
privadas y en espacios cerrados para
poder controlar el certificado de
vacunación de todos los invitados
[Música]
en múltiples ocasiones jugó más de ellos
es muy difícil para nosotros quedarnos
lejos de las calles pero no hay
alternativa
tenemos que controlar nuestra ansiedad
hacer lo que es posible mostrar nuestro
trabajo dentro de las posibilidades
actuales pero es otro año en que nos
sentimos frustrados por no estar en las
calles si dios quiere en 2023 si
estaremos
[Música]
hay un lado positivo en toda esta
historia ganamos un tiempo para
reestructurar nos y volver a pensar el
carnaval de una forma nueva pensar lo
que realmente queremos hacer en el
futuro qué ritmos y solo ritmos
brasileños la pandemia nos regaló un
tiempo para reestructurar niños brasil
estructurados
[Música]
si la pantalla en el coronavirus no
obliga a cancelar de nuevo los desfiles
2022 podría ser recordado como el año en
que río de janeiro tuvo dos carnavales
en febrero y en abril este ha sido
enlace conosur desde río de janeiro
brasil les invitamos a que sigan nuestra
programación en france24 en español
hasta pronto